In the previous unit, we have introduced the notion of NP-completeness.
We have seen that many practically relevant problems fall into this category,
such as vertex cover, clique, independent set, and of course the SAT problem
that we got to know in the last unit.
Now, since the famous P versus NP problem is unsolved,
there is no algorithm for any of these problems that is guaranteed
to run in polynomial time.
Now, in the first unit, we met three computer scientists
who were working on these problems,
and they did not know that their problems were NP-complete.
So, in this unit, what I would like to teach you is how you can detect
that a problem is NP-complete.
Then in the following units, we'll be dealing with counter measures.
Once you have found out that your problem is NP-complete what can you do about it?